- Woo, I need a beer.
(phone buzzes)
Hello?
- Hey man, sorry I'm running late.
I'm just looking for parking right now.
Man, I need a beer.
- I was literally just saying that.
- Hey, do you think I'm gonna
have a problem getting in?
I heard that place gets packed.
- No, you should be fine.
There's like literally
only one person here.
- Okay, cool.
- Yeah, it's super weird.
I've never been at a bar by myself before.
I'm just like people watching.
Like, this lady right here
is just literally bawling her eyes out.
- Hey Zack, just a
little pet peeve of mine,
but you shouldn't use the
word literally so loosely
because it means that--
- My eyes fell out, again.
- Yeah, no, but she's--
- No Zack, no more.
I'm your friend, I'm
only trying to help you.
- Okay, well, whatever.
Make sure that you're
wearing something kinda nice,
I feel a little under dressed right now.
- Oh, is there a dress code?
- I don't know, but this guy walked in
literally wearing a monkey suit.
- Zack, you have to stop saying literally.
- Okay, but he's literally--
- I don't want to hear it Zack.
You have to break this habit.
You sound like a fool.
- Okay, well you need to get here soon
'cause things literally just got crazy.
- Stop saying literally.
(rock music)
- It is nuts in here, I'm laughing so hard
I literally just peed my pants.
Hey, could I get a towel?
I just had a little accident.
- You say literally one more
time and I'm gonna hang up.
- Oh my gosh, I'm literally dying
of embarrassment right now.
- You know what Zack,
I'm not comin' anymore.
If you want to hang out with me,
you have to learn to use
proper English, all right?
I'm going home.
- I literally can't even.
- Goodbye.
That guy literally drives me crazy.
No.
(electronic music)
- I just checked Web M.D.,
this guy is literally
dying of a heart attack
after peeing his pants.